the house is expected to pass a
Republican bill today cutting taxes on
businesses and many individuals
President Trump accused Democrats of
quote obstruction and delay one new poll
finds that 52% of Americans disapprove
of the GOP tax plan Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill where the president will
meet with House Republicans before
today's vote Nancy good morning good
morning and he's got to be pleased with
how things look in the house the house
on the verge of passing a major GOP
priority massive corporate tax cuts and
individual tax payers many of them at
least would see cuts as well to their
taxes at least in the short term the
real drama however is unfolding in the
Senate where Republicans can only afford
to lose two of their own members and one
Republican Senator Ron Johnson of
Wisconsin said last night that he
opposes the current GOP plan because it
benefits larger corporations and does
not provide what he called fair
treatment for small businesses another
Republican Susan Collins of Maine joined
with Democrats who are outraged that a
repeal of Obama cares individual mandate
is now in the Senate plan she said that
adding a health care issue to the tax
bill quote does not make sense another
new addition to the Senate bill came
late last night when senator Deb Fischer
added a provision to give businesses a
tax break if they give their workers
paid family leave the Senate Finance
Committee is still debating that plan
and they're hoping to be able to pass it
on the Senate floor if they can keep all
those Republicans together gale early in
December so Nancy here's a question do
you think that there's a timeline to
have tax reform on the books by the end
of the year that you can see it is
possible if the House passes its bill
today and the Senate passes its version
the week after Thanksgiving then those
two bills would need to be reconciled
they're very different one for example
repeals the individual mandate the other
one doesn't but if they can do that
quickly and Republicans are very
motivated on this issue Gail it's
possible that they could then put one
bill to a vote in the House and the
Senate in time for the winter break but
everything would have to go perfectly
and tip
that's not the way it works around here
that's right quickly is the operative
word and the clock is ticking Thank You
Nancy
president Trump said though he wants a
bill by Christmas we shall see